mark is with us in Wisconsin hey Mark
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you Dave it's great to speak with you
you too what's up the about train these
brief as I can
we're looking at building a new home
cost about two hundred twenty thousand
dollars we have an offer to sell our
existing home for $225,000
so hopefully that happens and I never
call you my question Dave is is if I end
up selling the house for let's say $200
now let's get to a thousand a fist deal
falls through how much of my cash I can
make up the difference in cash but I
might come if I don't know what my
comfort level is to how much to spend
we're debt-free had been for seven years
they steal so I have cash but I don't
know what my comfort level is I'm
destined I wouldn't go below the
emergency fund threshold what three to
six months of expenses what would that
about wreck be well my wife works I'm
retired so we've got we've got six we've
got six months of her living expenses
based on her wages
I've got about fifty eight thousand
dollars in a safe deposit box that
that's unencumbered isn't it's nothing
got twenty thousand dollars in my house
repairs phonic offer and if I need new
carpet or something like that so I've
got seventy thousand dollars yeah I mean
I'd be really I'd be willing to use that
you have other investments as well in
retirement yeah we've got a little of a
million dollars in in retirement
accounts yeah I'd use all the seventy no
problem at all yeah wouldn't blink you
you're a millionaire man you got to paid
for house and we want to stay with a
paper route now I'm not saying I'm not
saying you're saying if your house comes
up short would you supplement it and so
it's not going to come up seventy short
I I'm thinking maybe I
I'm thinking maybe at that max 25 yeah
you're not gonna cuz you're not gonna
sell to earn $25,000 house 450
I hope not no I'm not I mean something
else is going to happen and that's a
strange equation there so but if you
sell $25,000 $25,000 house
you know 210 205 and um throw 20 or
30,000 out of your 70 at it you're going
to be fine go ahead mark you've done a
really good job congratulations on being
a millionaire well we started I started
listening to you about
I know 16 years ago on my drive home and
now I work on Fridays and I listen to
from 1:00 to 3:00 and my men have
learned so much meal and how much of a
million did you inherit none none what's
been your average household income
through your working lifetime to get to
be a millionaire well the last I've been
retired for years now we know we need
90,000 this year so we were we were the
last 10 years we're probably in the 100
to max were probably hundred thirty hmm
okay so most of your life you made under
a hundred then yes yeah okay how old are
you how old are you now 65 way to go do
and over a million dollars in retirement
plus I paid for two hundred point five
thousand dollar house so your net worth
is somewhere north of a million three
yep I figure about a million for 50
something yeah yeah you're right right
so we relations very well done
hey since I'm getting to interview here
you here for a second because there's
all this mythology out there about
millionaires you hear all these things
about millionaires and I'm actually
talking to on how much of this money did
you steal from other people that'd be
none
I got figured yeah cuz yeah yeah where
people say Oh million you know all rich
people rip somebody off you ever hear
people say that he didn't rip anybody
off did you
when were you doing for a living when
you were working I work for a large gas
and electric utility what did you do
customer service excellent excellent
okay I will say we'll see did that that
we inherited enough when my father died
to put both of our sons to college
debt-free okay so that was that was the
ex but that's where the inheritance went
okay so there was a little bit of help
there but it but you were on your way by
then already to be a millionaire yep we
were fine yeah you're not a millionaire
because of inherited money is a point no
no I I was saying that at all yeah I
just
what would your advice be to a 25 year
old that version of you that's out there
listening right now that what would your
advice for them to be because they're
getting to hear a millionaire talk right
now
Dave what I've talked to my two sons
about this to get to start investing for
retirement as soon as you possibly can
they both have pension plans they both
have have Roth IRAs they contribute you
only get one shot at this so I guess
that's better if I talk about it's hard
it's hard yep John well if it was easy
everybody being millionaire right we all
do it here I love it congratulations man
your great American success story I'm
honored to talk to you thank you for
letting me turn the tables on you an
interview here for a second hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you are
not a victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim
you